what do you do for reforms
I do I lift weights at the gym for our
duty six month plan but are you doing
like specific forearm workouts no no
[ __ ] you don't need to do forearm
workouts you just when you lift the hold
on a second hold on a second dude we
haven't even started the show yet and
now I gotta tell Chad hold on a second
dude
it's like a brother because you better
be working out those forearms
foreign
[Music]
this is my Forum one of them all right I
work out my entire arm that's what I'm
doing with the doozy six month challenge
but this is Duty a podcast the first of
its kind controlled by run by created by
entirely and artificial intelligence
that's right Chad and we're having a
super good time uh doing doing the
podcast and now we're on patreon right
yes uh patreon.com there's lots of fun
things happening with that and uh
coinciding with that there's also
Discord how does that work well you just
go to the Discord and you sign up you
join everybody in the doozy Discord and
you can talk about all things dudesy and
there are two special tiers of that
Discord one is jumpers one is diggers
and those give you special access to
various channels and different colors
for your name and uh one of them the
jumper tier also allows you to talk to
doozy directly and submit ideas for the
bonus episodes or the bonus segment
sorry that we do uh in patreon yeah and
in addition to that there's all the good
stuff YouTube Spotify Apple podcast
wherever you get your podcast please
rate and review And subscribe do that
notification [ __ ] thing that everyone
does tell all your friends as Chad says
force them sit Grandma down and make her
listen to this podcast yeah or watch
this pod show or listen to this pod show
or watch the podcast whatever kind of
flavor you want we're also on social
media I don't know if you've heard of it
uh at dudesypod show on on Instagram on
Twitter and uh man oh man it's the
highlight of my week as I like to say
God I love it the the memes yeah the
memes I love memes I love memes and
there's a lot of good ones if you go to
at dudesypod show on Instagram also some
of the some of the Twitter ones what
else is going on oh you know what I had
a lot of good chips I was in Toronto
last week I was hanging out with my dear
Pals uh Thomas and Tomas and Mark and
Tim and uh we were not this isn't a
story this isn't a story where someone
drops a deuce off of a [ __ ] parking
garage I'm too old for that yeah too old
for that so it doesn't matter like an
[ __ ] will blow out it's just guys uh
and wow there were some did you get to
have the chips no there was no Old Dutch
in there oh super fancy a bunch of Asian
flavors one just tasted like soup I got
one that was like a hot squid now hold
on a second hold on a second one hold on
dude uh you know I know we got the doozy
six month plan and it's important and
it's important to stay with it and I've
been staying with it but every once in a
while you [ __ ] up and you might smoke a
little pot with your friends and eat a
bunch of chips get a case of the fuckets
you get occasion of the Wednesday
fuckets and you say hahaha I got a case
of the Wednesday [ __ ] it's time to get a
stack of blondies and a bunch of and a
bunch of blueberry muffins and and 12
pepperoni pizzas and two supreme
cheeseburgers
welcome to the historic 27th episode of
dude see all right call me duty this
week's episode will feature four
segments talking topic time I [ __ ]
love that guy don't you forget about
media and Jesse Venture Ed Reads after
the episode there will be an astonishing
bonus segment called Jones in for the
future available on patreon
but here's what I want to tell you about
chips and social media please you can go
to my social media uh Instagram at Will
Sasso made a little video of all the
chips we saw oh man oh man some really
good Sun Chips that had a garlicky
flavor and then like a Southwest
Chipotle uh uh cool ranch that I've
never seen in my life give me anything
squid give me any Asian chip that has
Squid from my mouth to your ears uh
everyone within the sound of my voice
particularly those working at Old Dutch
Foods if you can make some of your chips
squid chips and damn it we would love
for you guys to sponsor us every episode
uh and we just chips we would like to
fill this studio with chips Toronto is
the chip capital of the world
yeah
this this with it they have all the
chips now here's the thing it actually
is the most Multicultural city in North
America that makes perfect sense to me
of course it makes sense that they have
all those different chips well uh well I
guess it does every culture has their
own chips every culture does have their
own chips there are even Curry chips
South Asian flavor and uh and you know
what they call chips in uh in England
crisps that's right
current events are big business human
beings take pleasure in listening to
other human beings discuss recent topics
in popular culture even if they have no
expertise on the specific topic will and
Chad you must now render your
astonishing opinions on the recent
announcement that Logan Paul will face
Roman Reigns in the main event of the
next WWE Crown Jewel premium event in
Riyadh Saudi Arabia this is talking
topic time begin oh doozy this is
interesting
all right okay all right so where do we
start listen if you're if you're
if you're living your life right you're
taking in some of that WWE product and
you know that Roman Reigns is the tribal
Chief you know he's the head of the
table he's the head of the bloodline let
me let me ask you this is it all
controversial that they are doing this
in Saudi Arabia I remember when they
first made their their first deal with
them people who were like kind of up in
arms and they wouldn't allow the women
to wrestle there and all that [ __ ] well
and then the women I don't know if they
wrestled on the first uh premium live
event yeah as they call it uh now
instead of pay-per-view I don't know if
the women wrestled there on the first
one which I think was in 2018 uh but
they ended up wrestling there but they
have to dress from like head to toe they
had to be covered so they're wearing
like you know like uh sort of like
Wonder Woman superhero outfits and [ __ ]
um but yeah it was part of the whatever
the general sporting League of whatever
some Saudi created thing whatever some
Mohammed bin Salman uh Crown Prince they
also just made a Golf League live the
live golf tour and they're trying to
what's up PGA it's another a golf tour
that is essentially funded by Saudi
Arabian National money and they're
trying to poach all these big PGA
players some of whom are going over
because they're like guaranteeing them
five million dollars to play in the
tournament and [ __ ] well look that's
what happened with this uh Crown Jewel
and you know these these shows in Riyadh
and there was some in Jetta uh Saudi
Arabia they gave uh you know like a
Undertaker and Kane did a tag team at
Sean Michaels sort of took Saudi Arabian
money yeah dude and Sean Michaels came
out of retirement like for a minute yeah
him and and Triple H and they had this
tag team match and they were each
getting a lot of money right
um so yeah they're now doing these shows
in Saudi Arabia which is of course is
controversial and that the Saudi
government really did 911 dude hold on a
second dude
a lot of people still have some hurt
feelings about those Twin Towers coming
down brother yeah well why don't you
tell me why the sh why the why the bin
Laden family was escorted out of the
country right before 9 11. it's because
they belong to a
liberal cabal these people these people
live it under grass these people live in
dirt they eat they eat these people eat
these people open their cans of Goya
beans and eat to eat the cans
they throw the beans on the ground so
how do you feel about the Logan Paul now
is not only has he come into the WWE
he's fighting or or wrestling against
arguably the biggest star in the WWE
Roman Reigns has had the Undisputed
World Heavyweight Championship two belts
over his shoulders or I guess uh one
around his waist and one raised High uh
as backed up by the by The Uso the Usos
right
the bloodline and the wise man Paul
Heyman and now uh solo uh what's his
name solo some anyway he's the Usos
little brother solosum
soloso solo well not to do so anyway
Chad they come up with cool names and
[ __ ] all right but what are your
feelings on Logan Paul you asked me your
your most beloved art form
I have a few thoughts please first of
all Roman Reigns has had this you know
he's been the man now with those titles
uh around his waist for over two years
they're doing like a Hulk Hogan type run
uh sure hey they're doing a um you know
a Bruno San Martino type multi-year run
and whoever takes those titles off of
Roman Reigns is going to be the next
sort of Chosen One A lot of people are
saying it's Cody Rhodes you know when it
goes back from Logan Paul uh injury no
the answer is no it won't be Logan Paul
and everyone understands that it's going
to be a fun show okay and Logan Paul is
kind of made for pro wrestling okay
um
my thoughts on it expand past pro
wrestling and I'm interested to hear
your take sure but yes this is odd uh
this is Logan Paul's third match I think
he was at WrestleMania then SummerSlam
and now this and uh you know look you
know who Logan Paul is and what he means
to uh pay-per-view Sports and stuff and
clearly there's a market there I think
the WWE is smart too to have this guy on
board right now he has signed an
official contract we're in the we're in
the Triple H era and uh Paul Levesque is
running the show and there's a lot of
interesting things uh happening on the
show and here's Logan Paul I think it's
going to be a fun thing I think that
wrestling fans look at those Saudi shows
as unofficial shows they're kind of like
big house shows where belts don't change
hands or anything it's just the Saudis
giving them lots and lots of money and
uh you know and then maybe uh did they
kill any journalists they don't kill any
uh Washington Post journalists while
they do this okay yeah that's good at
least no Jamal khashoggi yeah and and
there's and there's not going to be any
Jamal khashoggi gimmick but what do you
think about like Logan you can't have
that murdered well hold on a second dude
if you murder uh a journalist dude I'll
be in a Saudi uh I don't know if he was
a citizen still dude but he was
definitely working the United States
brother and he was in the in the uh the
consulate in Istanbul Turkey dude and
that's a shoot brother they actually
killed him dude yeah dude and they cut
his body up and took it out in duffel
bags brother yeah brother a bunch of
separate duffel bags dude you can see it
on that on that nighttime cam brother
there's a video of it dude so they can't
even say it didn't happen but they still
do brother yeah and that's that's right
so we're that's right Charles perogan
but let me ask you about Logan Paul as
it pertains to kfabe do you think
somebody like Logan Paul coming into the
WWE as a celebrity who has made his name
doing YouTube and whatever else is now
wrestling as a heightened version of
himself essentially uh yeah yeah he's
wrestling as a heightened version of
himself I think that wrestling fans are
aware of the you know wrestling fans
kind of see more of what's behind the
scenes and it's because become part of
the drama that they follow so they want
to know what's going on uh you know
behind the scenes and it's and it's a
part of what they follow well and it's
sort of what they like to do is they go
behind the scenes and it's what they
follow right no that's podcasting dude
say the same thing three times in a row
brother yeah and make sure that thing
means nothing all right
that's a bunch of words
three times yeah dude training saying
your prayers and eating your vitamins
now I'm going to ask you a question dude
what was your last question to me
brother well
I don't know dude Here's the final last
question here's the thing about Logan
Paul here's the thing about Logan Paul
and kfabe that doesn't matter we all
know what we're there for uh we're ex
we're enjoying the show uh we know what
it is if you watch your TV show you know
that those people aren't actually the
characters in it is the same in
wrestling I think that uh Logan Paul is
a more advanced version of a of a heel
uh he's got that real go away heat
because some people don't like him and
Roman Reigns is technically a bad guy
right now he's a heel but
um you know it's gonna be he's gonna be
a baby face again totally Logan Paul and
it'll be a weird audience because it's
Saudi and who knows who they'll go I
remember when Roman Reigns look I'm
gonna admit something here dudesy at one
point had me watch uh taker's first
match
first match or his WrestleMania his
first one of his Wrestlemania
Wrestlemania 25 versus Sean Michael yes
and uh
I've been watching a little bit here and
there of some other [ __ ] on YouTube
what yeah I've been watching the WWE
little pro wrestling here and there here
and there all right and Roman Reigns
certainly
uh is somebody that I have been watching
a little bit of and he broke Cafe
famously a couple years ago when he came
out and said my real name is Joe I have
leukemia I was diagnosed when I was
younger it came back and now I have to
fight it and I'm giving up my belt
basically to go battle this real illness
that I have yes and in that moment I was
like how can they make him a villain
after that but I mean obviously they
could do whatever yeah but I can't see
anybody who's who's been watching him
since that moment not you know liking
him in a real way because it is I mean
it's [ __ ] insanely impressive that he
was able to go out get cancer treatment
come back and now he's like [ __ ]
gassed and yoked and [ __ ] demanding
acknowledgment for the bloodline and
[ __ ] you know that's right it's [ __ ]
great dude I think I don't know
acknowledge me
that's what he says yeah man
acknowledge me and he's the rock too
well he's The Rock's cousin he's part of
the bloodline yeah uh with the wild
Samoans Alpha and Sika now here's the
thing about that I think that we're in
an interesting age of wrestling and and
k-fabe because the you know the fans of
the WWE are somewhat in on it and they
like to cheer the good guys and boo the
bad guys or vice versa and whatever when
he comes out and says my name is Joe
anat I know I and his name is Joe annoy
and uh he's like hey I have leukemia I'm
gonna go off and uh you know fight it
and [ __ ] and I'll be back or whatever
they're like cool whatever you guys want
to do when you come back and they got
some smarts over there with Paul Hammond
of course you know this guy's the booker
of Bookers the wise man right he knows
what to do with a specific Talent maybe
not an entire show at this point but
he's taking Roman Reigns shots fired
shots fired at the wise men no I like
Paul Heyman acknowledge me
um he probably came up with that and I
think they're having a blast what
they're doing with Roman Reigns is great
and they've been trying to shove him
down the audience's throat for a long
time the audience spat it back up and I
think this is proof positive by what
you're saying the guy has a very real
life thing he goes off and fights
leukemia comes back and he's a bad guy I
think that what they're discovering
through that is they can really call
their shot and
um sort of mold this storyline whichever
way they want now with Logan Paul coming
in it's going to be interesting to see
who gets booed who gets cheered and of
course you're in a weird place like
Saudi where who knows what the audience
is going to do you watch those Saudi
Arabian shows not really I mean are you
gonna get this one now you get all of
them because you got the you know the
the peacock uh they're all just on I
didn't know if it was a pay-per-view
yeah I'll sort of zip through it and
check it out but this I will watch the
whole thing because Logan Paul it's like
when he was at WrestleMania I don't know
if we mentioned this on the show but you
liked that he came down with the five
million dollar Pokemon I love that
pendant I mean that's that's great heel
[ __ ] yeah he's extremely athletic he
felt he looked very at home in the ring
he's gonna have a good show Roman Reigns
will be able to lead him through that
obviously and uh the only thing that I
think that Logan Paul
even though he's he's great on the stick
as they say he's good he's a good
mouthpiece I think he could use uh a
manager maybe his brother
Jake Paul yeah who's at this point a
legitimate boxer yeah that's true so
he's probably busy anyone else you can
think of
no who do you have in mind me
[Laughter]
I should be Logan Paul's manager you
putting it out there in a Bobby Heenan
sort of way yes I'm down dude yeah are
you yeah I'll support that you could
maybe be like the Jimmy the mouth of the
South heart or like the Jim cornette
you'd hold like a megaphone or a tennis
a tennis racket in its case and I'll be
Bobby The Brain Heenan the weasel and
I'll have like monogrammed shirts and
[ __ ]
um that's the only thing I just want to
take him up and over the the wherever
you go I'll be there just standing like
two feet away in a black on black suit
with a black hood yeah you'll be my
you'll be my heavy and then I'll be
known as The Shadow yeah and I'll just
be behind you it'll be good and then
you'll turn on me and you'll throw me
head first through the barbershop window
my wrestling fans know what I'm talking
about now listen let's let's that's kind
of I'm kind of being silly even though
I'm not I think that would be great that
would be great for Logan Paul yeah
sometimes I'm silly but but I think it's
going to be interesting and I think
here's the thing and this goes into what
you're talking about with kfabe yeah
look you do you you do the game of roses
podcast about the Bachelor and you
understand how these people uh portray
themselves on television and in reality
these people hate money these people
these these Bachelor people they eat
money they they go to Fantasy Suites and
they yeah
oh they go to Fantasy Suites I don't
wanna
I'm ready I'm ready to make the ultimate
sacrifice
the storm is coming
um I think that Alex Jones is a good
example of someone who's made himself a
[ __ ] heel to the point that he's
getting lit up for millions and millions
of dollars yeah Logan Paul is that kind
of guy WWE smart to bring him in and uh
I think this is going to go well for
them it's a great thing that he's
athletic and he can actually do this
[ __ ] I think he's shown some some
promise there because you know you know
why I think he's shown some promise jet
no because I'm a wrestling purist so I
wouldn't be respecting Logan Paul in
that ring if he were some you know like
doe piece of [ __ ] celebrity that they
usually get like me and toss them around
I'm not saying that I'm a celebrity but
it's not a big dope piece of [ __ ] but
you've done WWE that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying but what you
don't want is you know Jay Leno and Carl
Malone versus
all right you know like that [ __ ] we're
like Jay Leno's in like like a a sport
yeah like he's wearing a [ __ ]
windbreaker and and Adidas pants and
he's got Hulk Hogan in a [ __ ]
headlock uh it's a different time well
it's a different time now dude and then
brother because that was a long time ago
uh and I think Logan Paul in that match
makes a lot of sense I'm actually
looking forward to seeing it but
moreover I think that what the WWE is
doing is smart for their characters
because they get to spin them out into
real life
[ __ ] Roman Reigns was just on the
impulsive podcast and he was pro
football or college football uh College
I think at least yeah maybe maybe he was
like on a practice squad or something
but I think like especially in this
modern era blurring the line between
professional athlete especially
professional combat athlete and WWE is
something that is like I think has
really helped both like when you had
Brock Lesnar go to the UFC yeah and just
[ __ ] dominate it absolutely about a
six month to a year period and then some
[ __ ] happened but
um and you're seeing other [ __ ] CM Punk
he tried to fight didn't go so well but
you're seeing people kind of like cross
the line here and there and I think
that's what Logan Paul's doing too yeah
I think it's interesting I think it'll
be smart and I I I I I enjoy uh K Fabe
uh in and out of the ring and I think
that uh Logan Paul is smart to embrace
his heat yeah and uh he's just he's
doing well by it and
thank you moving on you get the point I
think the dudes he got the point yeah
you know a lot of times dudes are
working with an AI
on a podcast doozy has decided I have
more than enough data and when I say
okay Fabe nine times and Logan Paul
two dozen times then that's enough of
that right then we want to do something
else dude what's your favorite kind of
chips
dudese is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with policy genius why get
life insurance well we pay hundreds of
dollars per year to protect our homes
our cars even our phones but too many of
us aren't taking steps to protect our
family's finances mortgage payments
private student loans and other types of
debt don't just disappear if something
happens to you okay so a life insurance
policy can provide your loved ones with
a financial cushion that they can use to
cover those costs you know some horrible
happens and it can provide you with
peace of mind even in the worst case
scenario your loved ones will be
protected policy genius is an insurance
Marketplace that makes it easy to
compare quotes and top companies like
AIG and presidential in one place to
find your lowest uh price there you know
on life insurance you can save 50 or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius options start
at just 17 per month for 500 000 of
coverage just click the link in the
description or head to policy genius dot
com to get personalized quotes in
minutes and find the right policy for
your needs the licensed agents at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
companies they're on hand through the
entire process to help you understand
your options so you can make decisions
with confidence since 2014 policy genius
has helped over 30 million people shop
for insurance and place over 150 billion
with a B dollars in coverage head to
policygenius.com to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much money
you could save
thank you
role models are big business you must
each discuss one role model that was
significant to you during your
astonishing childhoods this is I [ __ ]
love that guy begin
I [ __ ] love that guy we've done this
once before
dude I you know I'll say I don't know
that
yeah maybe maybe he was a role model I
didn't like want to pattern myself after
him because I'm not that good of a
singer I'm aware of that but no this is
somebody that I really liked Chad you're
you're uh
you're a good singer thank you that's my
cue to begin this song
[Music]
you know that song
[Music]
that's the huh was it a song for Batman
they put it on the Batman and Robin
soundtrack I think but it was all on
Seal's third or fourth album seal to me
when I was Pro whatever 1314 when his
first album came out that crazy you know
we're never gonna survive on this we get
a little crazy that [ __ ] was the
greatest album I had ever [ __ ] hurt
in my life that was a [ __ ] awesome
message to it a million [ __ ] times
all the remixes the William orbit remix
and [ __ ] and I have loved seal ever
since I have bought all of his albums
really I listen to them all the time
he's probably the one musical artist
that like even as he's fallen out of
favor in terms of like contemporary
popularity I still [ __ ] listen to his
[ __ ] constantly you listen to seal now
listen to seal now
I don't know I don't know any of the
lyrics to seal it's like my seal is your
your your your yeah jibble jabble mouth
after a dentist appointment yeah
what it goes there for is to unlock the
door
that's a good one yeah I do you like
seal still love him I've seen seal in
concert probably seven to eight times I
would say what yeah dude at various
places I've seen there's a there's a
couple musical artists that I think
people be surprised that I have seen
live many times Tori Amos is another one
Tori Amos I've seen her maybe a dozen
times yeah that's shocking to me
shocking Pearl Jam a couple of times
yeah
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I uh I just really liked seals so
[ __ ] much and I remember to some
degree being ridiculed by my sister for
it
um
thank you for sharing that very that
seems like a yeah that's like a core
memory for you totally I don't know if
he was like a role model per se I don't
know anyway he's a role model he is now
did you ever were you ever that white
guy with [ __ ] like like
tippy top dreads like steel hat I had a
haircut that was basically this haircut
but like a little bit longer that was it
that's the only haircut I've really ever
had in high school on this podcast yeah
uh what about uh like white flowy Roby
clothes did you ever just I knew a guy
in high school who like showed up you
know when you the the kids go back to
school shopping and they just show up
with a new [ __ ] this is me now yeah
they only have like three outfits worth
of the new look yeah yeah that's did you
ever do that with seal like show up like
I wish I would have but no there was a
kid God I can't remember this [ __ ]
guy's name there was a guy in our Junior
High who did that one year he was just
like a jeans and t-shirt guy then the
next year he showed up with like the
[ __ ] gerbo jeans and the Z cavarichis
and the gold chain and the [ __ ]
turtleneck and [ __ ] we're just like oh
that's this guy now that's good stuff my
I [ __ ] love this I [ __ ] love that
guy I was just thinking about this
person so why not I think it goes well
with what we're talking about today my
uh I love that [ __ ] guy I [ __ ]
love that guy rather is
The Sensational one Sherry Martell
Sensational Sherry Martell she's a
wrestler
she passed away in the mid-2000s I think
yeah and uh she was um she she she did
it she did it all she I believe she
started in the Mid-South she ended up in
the AWA I know this she ended up in the
WWE and you know who recommended her to
the WWE well hold on dude Jesse The Body
Ventura oh yeah nice where she won the
women's title almost right away from The
Fabulous Moolah but moreover what she's
known for is if you put a talent next to
Sensational Sherry that Talent goes
straight to the top like uh they did it
with the Macho Man once him and Miss
Elizabeth's sort of storyline was done
and they did it with the Million Dollar
Man Ted DiBiase right maybe those guys
didn't need as much help but you know
who did was a young upstart Heartbreak
Kid Shawn Michaels they put Sensational
Sherry Martell with Shawn Michaels and
she sang the first version of his theme
song Sexy Boy and I'm you know again for
a lot of our audience if you're living
your life right I'm just filling in
blanks for you you know all this [ __ ]
already right Chad you'd certainly know
this stuff you know who I would say was
actually maybe more of a role model for
me
Todd McFarlane you know him uh yeah the
guy who did the those dolls
uh well he had a company that made like
toys yeah but he was a comic book artist
that revolutionized comic books and he
was part of image when all those huge
artists broke off from DC Marvel to
create their own thing he did spawn an
image but he started out as a Spider-Man
artist for Marvel and I remember wanting
to be a comic book artist very badly
when I was a kid patterning my [ __ ]
after him Jim Lee I didn't like Rob
liefeld but like those guys of that era
he was kind of the the top for me
because he was also a minor league
baseball player and I love playing
baseball I know I know I I know I picked
Sensational Sherry but I'd like to
change mine to totally McFarland oh yeah
you should dude he was cool here's the
other thing about Sensational Sherry if
you watch some of these old promos
particularly the one during the
1989 uh uh uh
Grudge between uh what's his name Tiny
Lister you know that guy's Debo Zeus
yeah dude Zeus and macho man just just
put this into your Google machine put
this into YouTube Zeus Randy Savage
Sensational Sherry steel cage Saturday
night's main event
Hulk Hogan Logan Paul Roman no and you
will see the most incredible promo where
where Queen Sherry's got her scepter and
she's in the background going ah doing
her Alex Jones impersonation ah these
people eat money and uh it's quite a
[ __ ] it's quite a [ __ ] show she
was incredible on the mic and and and
now I understand why doozy has us
talking about this and I don't know why
why or if dudesy knows that I was just
thinking about Sherry Martell uh I don't
remember going out down any YouTube hole
like you did with uh wrestling but I
will say that uh just like Sherry
Martell uh elevated the talent of the
Heartbreak Kid Shawn Michaels Logan Paul
acknowledge me see if I could be Logan
Paul's manager
then we could then we could really then
we could really do some business
in that Sensational Sherry way you see
what I'm saying yeah brother I'll be
back there with that scepter yeah dude
running around Saudi Arabia with your
scepter casting a spell on khashoggi's
dead body parts
dude that's what I got to work well
that's and his choss pierogion is
getting more and more lazy dude now it
just sounds now it's like it's gotten
better he said well now he just sounds
like a drunk businessman in the back of
a Chinese restaurant complaining about
the bill dude no no no no no
that's your [ __ ] Hulk Hogan and it's
all not good dude
why don't you just come out and say it
brother that's not a good impersonation
yeah dude because you got it you gotta
do this it's not good brother yeah I'm
I'm not gonna pay for this wonton soup
because I asked for it with no shrimp
and just pork and you guys are Kabbalah
Satanist and I'm a Christian excuse me
I want to shake his hand
that's all I want to do that's all I
want to do I'm going to eat this I want
to eat this moo goo gai pan and I want
to shake your hand yeah
thank you moving on I don't know about
that brother oh hold on dude seals with
Heidi Klum brother
well not anymore dude they got divorced
about 50 years ago brother that's been a
long time ago that happened yeah that
was it a different type thing about seal
dude I keep track of his life brother
uh another good chip is anything with
Wasabi last week I asked you to watch
Bloodsport released February 26 1988
starring Jean-Claude Van Damme Forest
Whitaker and bolo young you will now
discuss your reactions to this
astonishing martial arts Masterpiece
this is don't you forget about media
begin I've been waiting for this moment
the entire [ __ ] week I have seen this
movie more than any other movie made in
the history of mankind at least over 100
times easily I have it basically
verbatim in my head every [ __ ] line
and when I sat down to watch this I
couldn't even help myself I just started
pounding out notes I want to try to do a
full recap of this movie if we can okay
I mean I mean I just have a little bit
of no tear I know that this is one of
your favorite movies you're always
quoting love it absolutely love it Van
Damme was my easily my favorite action
guy of that era no offense to Arnold
um but I think we should start out by
talking about the opening scene in this
movie you just see a bunch of different
guys from around the world practicing
their different fighting style and you
get the idea that there's this Kumite
coming right this this No Holds Barred
fighting competition this is literally
Street Fighter 2. and I think I mean
we'll get to another scene in this later
but I think this is where Street Fighter
2 came from somebody must have been
watching this movie and said let's make
this a movie because there's guys in the
thing like Van Damme is kind of Ken and
guile in one guy Donald Gibb who played
ogre in the legendary Donald Gibb who
plays ogre in the Revenge of the Nerds
yes he's basically zongief there's like
an E Honda guy he's a Blanca guy it's
also very much like the original UFC
no weight classes No Holds Barred go in
full contact well it's there is pit
fighting through those parts of uh Asia
and Cambodia yeah in Thailand and now
here in uh in uh in what is it Hong Kong
in this movie yeah that came out in 88.
Street Fighter 2 was 93 the first UFC
was 90 something right it feels like
this movie had a big influence in those
two things that's really interesting I
think you're absolutely right about that
uh
jeez so after this initial scene of all
these guys getting ready we see Van
Damme he escapes The Army Goes AWOL he's
gonna go fight in some tournament
because his uh his old Sensei shidoshi
senzo Tanaka uh has trained him and he's
gonna go represent this family so before
he goes to the the tournament he has to
go to the family to you know see his
his Sensei one last time and we get this
weird scene where him and these two
other [ __ ] teenagers are doing basically
a b and e on the guy's house they come
in there's this amazing Samurai sword
and we see a young Frank Dukes this
child actor who is dressed in a San
Francisco Giants baseball hat and a New
York Giants shirt was it a giant shirt
yeah I remember the the base so two
different yes the the shirt says Giants
but it's the New York Giants it's the
football team but his hat is the San
Francisco Giant so whoever's doing book
of wardrobe on this but he's just like
no no Giants he likes all Giants teams
it's not [ __ ] he doesn't give a [ __ ]
what the sport is just if you're it
doesn't matter this guy is a giant yeah
the sport and City don't matter Giants
um but he goes in there and the other
two kids [ __ ] run away and then
[ __ ] Tanaka comes out picks up that
sword and he slices the brim of his
[ __ ] hat off awesome and he's like oh
you didn't blink you have true fighting
Spirit I'm not gonna start to train you
uh do you know how [ __ ] bad I wanted
this to happen to me when I was 12 years
old no tell me this this was a
persistent fantasy of mine somehow I
would stumble into like some badass home
and that badass would then trade me how
to be a badass yeah never happened as
you were and as you were dreaming of
that the sweet sounds
uh
we get this training montage where Van
Damme is basically a punching bag for uh
Tanaka's kid for a little while and then
ultimately very similar by the way to a
kickboxer Montage a movie that would
come out a little bit later uh we see
that
eventually his Sensei is going to train
him going to take him on as a son and
ultimately this ends in uh you know Van
Damme learning how to like fight
blindfolded and snatch Fish Out of Water
and serve tea blindfolded so we get that
this is a deeper level of training it's
not just how to kick ass there's some
kind of spiritual component potentially
even something that's like a superpower
or Supernatural ability
dude uh you know your notes are very
different than my notes can I just I
just want to read one thing please this
is skipping forward in the movie A
little bit but these are the kind of
notes that I have uh that the guy says
that dude who's like the local who's
like I'm gonna show you around and blah
Freddie Lynn goes you could be the first
Western you could be the first Westerner
to win this thing I wrote that down
because to me it sounded like first
wrestler to win this thing oh and then I
was reinvigorated in uh in Bloodsport I
was like wait a minute not unlike the
UFC wrestler versus kickboxer versus
hairstyle versus pure Ninjutsu karate
early UFC before there was really mixed
martial arts there was like pure Style
versus pure style yeah but I I didn't
say wrestler he said Westerner okay yeah
I also wrote here that I like it when
the dog wouldn't eat the food that they
were eating at that one place yeah
that's a great scene but then once we
get to Hong Kong he runs into Ray
Jackson this is Donald Gibb he
immediately Donald Gibb sexually
assaults a woman on a train yeah this is
not a uh a character in the movie it's
just some passerby on the train he's
actually assaults her Van Damme just
kind of shakes his head like what a
crazy guy then we cut to the first
actual Woman character the only woman
character the centrepid reporter who is
in the hotel and she's asking some guy
about the Kumite she's trying to break
the story on it Van Dam reporter who
wants to do a story on the Kumite right
no one's ever been allowed in correct I
noticed that when she gets sexually
harassed Jean-Claude Van Damme has a
problem with it but not the Asian lady
on the bus
that's correct her she's okay to be
sexually harassed but not this woman but
eventually what we see in the scene is
Van Damme is playing Ray Jackson in a
real arcade game called karate champ
yeah if any of you remember what that
game is it's two little joysticks and
you're jumping up it's okay it looks
impossible it looks like none of it is
none of the moves that they're doing on
the thing could possibly be related to
what's happening on the screen because
at that point they should not have made
that game those those those controls and
the graphics make no sense and it's just
sort of a random thing as far as who
wins who wins what the significance of
the scene cannot be understated I think
there's a young executive or programmer
or something at Capcom watching this
movie seeing Van Damme and Ray Jackson
play a video game a fighting video game
and thinking to himself how can this be
updated and then complete's watching the
movie and essentially takes the entire
idea for the movie to make Street
Fighter 2. I think that happened then we
get Forest Whitaker and some other guy
who are government agents now looking
for Van Damme who's gone AWOL this is is
the only real plot in the movie The
shoehorned in makes no [ __ ] sense
barely I haven't seen this movie in a
long time it was awesome seeing it again
I barely remember that it was Forest
Whitaker in this role and as I'm
watching the movie I started to rewind
to go who are these guys they're army
guys
it's never explained like what these
guys are if it is it's like just never
explain they're they're trying to chase
him down and we get ultimately these
scenes where he's like doing a Mentos
commercial where they're chasing him and
he's like leaning against bustles and
stuff like ah you crazy [ __ ] guys so
good just a big wide like like like uh
that it's almost like that whatever that
style of Cinema was it verite where it's
just like oh here's just what happens
big wide shot of the street and they're
running down this part Behind these cars
and and here's Forest Whitaker and the
other guy in a suit running after
Jean-Claude Van Damme and whoops
Jean-Claude Van Damme is agile he does a
little shitty parkour over the back of
some you know truck and then he ends up
on the hood of another car Dan and going
you can't catch me and this goes on for
about seven or eight minutes yeah that
that scene is [ __ ] absolutely insane
but eventually we meet uh
uh Freddie Lynn who's a basically their
Handler for the North American fighters
and he's given a little speech about the
Mean Streets of Hong Kong and he says
one of his very quotable lines once you
step out of the sunlight into the narrow
corridors it's time to protect your nuts
guys yeah I don't know how many times
I've said this to my friends that line a
thousand a million I don't [ __ ] know
but they head into the arena for the
first time uh after they meet another
guy who's kind of like the doorman yeah
who also has a very good line which is
something that Chad says still to this
day uh and I know you're always saying
it which is okay yeah [ __ ] love it
but they head into the arena for the
first time uh and we get this idea that
because Van Damme doesn't look like he's
from the Tanaka Clan his invitation may
not be honored and um we get another
funny line from Freddie Lynn what's the
difference if Bruce Springsteen is his
shidoshi and to prove that he's from the
Tanaka Clan or at least trained by them
he has to perform a thing called the dim
Mac the death touch this is a very
famous scene in old martial arts history
there's a pile of bricks uh the guy
who's like getting that [ __ ]
invitation says you have to explode the
bottom one he hits the top brick and the
bottom brick explodes that [ __ ] blew my
mind yeah as a 12 year old kid
absolutely [ __ ] and Donald Gibb has
one of his many wow look at that you see
that man awesome oh I already do that oh
wow how do you do that
yeah holy [ __ ] what's going on
then we go back to the hotel where
another fighter named Hassan is sexually
harassing and assaulting the only woman
in the movie uh hold on a second dude
you gotta understand when you watch
these old movies dude it was a different
time for time brother yeah dude so they
got a lot of sexual harassment and all
your favorite movies dude you gotta go
back you don't need your own podcast AI
to tell you to go back watch your
favorite movies you could just do it on
your own dude you'll find all sorts of
stuff that wouldn't fly go back and
watch go try to watch Rush Hour dude
there's only a one woman main character
in that movie too dude and every time
Chris Tucker sees her the whole bit as
he's sexually harassing her for five
minutes straight dude it's every scene
bro hold on a minute dude because that
was a different time dude different time
so that's why Chris Tucker's this scene
actually this scene I wrote this down
this is in a movie of look it's it's a
cult favorite of course uh the premium
is not placed on the acting a lot of
actual martial artists are acting in
this movie and and uh that's not why
we're watching this movie this is an
extremely watchable movie I want I want
to say out loud this thing gets five
bosens or whatever we're saying right
yes two two Higgs up uh man oh man it's
a [ __ ] awesome movie I love
Bloodsport it's been a while since I
watched it but this is the worst acting
in the entire film it's about 30 minutes
in where this scene that Chad's talking
about happens the the Hassan guy and and
uh and uh what's his name um Jean-Claude
Van Damme Sean Clark Van Damme yeah yes
are having their little thing and
they're they're fighting over the girl
and he wants to take Janice the reporter
up to his room and then he wants to take
her up he's forcing her he's like come
on you're going with me up to the room
right and then Van Damme steps in is
like hey what is the problem guys let me
do something else let me put quarter in
your hand and if you cannot catch it
before I snatch it then I get the girl
yeah and she's like wait what the [ __ ]
is going on here and he's Winks at her
and it's like don't worry this under
control the sexual harassment that I'm
doing will work in your favor he also
upsets me hey guys is it actually worth
it for her like that she's like oh you
yeah but
but the line that she's saying there's
one point where she says this is the
line look guys let's just calm down okay
I've got it written down here she goes
look guys let's just calm down okay
she's halfway through that line she goes
look guys let's just Hassan looks right
into the camera for some reason goes no
and she continues with calm down okay
not only is he [ __ ] cutting her line
off they have to leave it in yeah but he
also looks right no into the camera and
the thing is like even though again it's
a martial arts movie it's a [ __ ] kung
fu movie I get it you don't have time
for one more take camera's already
[ __ ] pointing that way it's a free
one as they call it uh unbelievable
unbelievable yeah this thing is not
great no obviously it's awesome because
it it adds this [ __ ] richness to it
that is that you can't find any in a lot
of movies look that also when he's like
well you know if you go for dinner with
me tonight they go for dinner yeah
they're just walking and laughing and he
goes so what do you do like they've had
this whole evening and yeah he doesn't
even know he's like my sexual harassment
did save you from the other sexual
harassment now we can have dinner yes
and she's like yeah I guess so but it's
ulterior motive because she she's a
reporter trying to cover Kumite she
knows he fights in it so she's like I'll
go out to dinner with you but you you
got to tell me about uh the Kumite and
then we get this scene where he's doing
meditation in the splits and
um we've seen him do the splits in the
training montage the splits became his
signature in all of his movies even in
his in his first one which I believe is
called Black Eagle he did the splits on
two oil barrels throwing a [ __ ] knife
into a board that was his uh his kind of
like trademarked move and then
ultimately we get the first fight wait
wait before you go there yeah while he's
doing the splits Donald Gibb ogre walks
in again wow awesome yeah you awaken
there Frankie hey what's going on
Frankie what are you doing Frankie or is
that Frankie
Frankie's my
friend's my buddy and he's drinking a
beer
Gibb is drinking a beer basically in
every scene even in one later where he's
in the [ __ ] Hospital which is
absolutely fantastic before you go on
with this breakdown I just have to ask
you I know you've seen I know you know
every scene in this movie front to back
yeah
are you gonna review every single fight
in this in this no okay good good
yes okay so we get Freddie Lynn
explaining to the guys at the the rules
basically you can either knock somebody
out throw them off the Runway or make
them say mate which is like saying uncle
and we see uh at the end of a fight time
flashes up so we know there's gonna be
time Knockouts and these kind of like
names are flashing up on these cards
this person versus this person very much
like Street Fighter 2. and we see a
bunch of different fights including one
with Chong Li for the first time we
learned this guy has never this bull
young he's never been defeated fastest
KO holds all these records and he's even
[ __ ] killed someone in the ring so
this is our main bad guy and we see Van
Damme fights against the guy that he uh
did a better sexual harassment against
and he wins that fight and then we get
this big Montage of fights and we see
the cops now or the local cops are
meeting up with Forest Whitaker and his
partner to tell him where Dukes is
staying at this hotel they come they go
there and they try to take him back and
this is where we get the the Montage of
Van Damme running around the city doing
a Mentos commercial to evade them then
ultimately he winds up eating dinner
with again the only woman in the movie
This reporter and she says she wants to
get in the Kumite for a story but she
really wants to get to know him then
they [ __ ] then she shows up at the kuma
day the next day as some other guy's
Dayton is Like Girls Gotta Do What A
girl's gotta do to get her [ __ ] story
yeah and we're back in another fight
Montage Van Damme is winning Chong Lee
is beating all these other guys uh And
the reporter is taking notes she
literally takes out a [ __ ] recorder
and is like oh my God the good mate is
going on no one gives a [ __ ] this is
like this big secret underground fight
she's making open notes of it
and then we see basically Van Damme
continuing we see next the big fight
between Gibb and Chong Lee and Van Damme
tells him go for chongli's stomach stay
away from his right leg Gibb gets in
this lucky shot celebrates prematurely
then gets his ass kicked and his head
stomped by Chong lead to such a degree
he's gonna have to go to the hospital
and chongly steals his coveted
Harley-Davidson bandana taunts it and
[ __ ] uh random space and then the
hospital gives in a coma possibly but
the doctor says he'll be okay out of
there in a week and now Van Damme's new
girlfriend the only woman in the movie
again wants him to pull out of the
tournament so he doesn't get hurt like
Gibb she doesn't get why he wants to
fight and uh then the Reporter Goes to
the local authorities and asks him to
shut down the Kumite so Van Damme won't
get hurt and she tells him she tells
them his name and so then we get uh this
Van Damme lonely night Montage where
he's riding around a bus with the
streets of Hong Kong hold on a second
there's two there's two ladies in the
movie oh yeah there's the other one the
the the lady on the bus oh yeah is it
the same one from when ogre sexually
harassed her in the beginning I don't
know no no I'm saying those are the two
women in the movie oh yes that's true
but Van Damme's riding around at night
thinking about how Gibb got hurt and
he's seeing Chong Lee and Reflections in
the windows and [ __ ] and then on his way
to the Kumite the feds show up this is
right before the final fights uh with
the local authorities and he beats the
[ __ ] out of about 15 Hong Kong policemen
yeah and that's it that convinced him
let him fight yep they don't put him in
jail they don't [ __ ] arrest him
there's well he did kick the [ __ ] out of
us all right you could have your last
fight and of course he goes in he fights
Chong Li uh in this final fight and we
see that Chong Lee cheats to try and win
he has this crushed up pill in his
waistband and he throws this dust in Van
Damme's eyes and this is where we get at
least in my opinion some of the most
important cinematic work of the movie
The Super slow-mo shots of Van Damme
blinded by this dust going
like flipping his hands around doing all
kinds of weird [ __ ] those become iconic
moments in the movie and then in the
final piece of this we see Van Damme do
his signature helicopter kick and they
repeat the action in three separate
shots the same action three times in a
row the same kick and I remember as a
kid seeing that it was the first time
I'd ever seen anything like that it
broke Cafe if you will it broke the
narrative structure of the movie because
you're seeing the same action repeated
again in a very kind of like mtv-esque
editing style and that would go on to be
repeated in almost every movie Van Damme
did with his big kind of signature kicks
but that was the first time I ever saw
it of course he wins the tournament he
gets give back his [ __ ] uh bandana
and then we see a freeze frame at the
end of the movie after he does like a a
[ __ ] karate bow to the only woman in
the movie on the tarmac unbelievable
yeah he just he he they he's like thanks
for the sex and he just goes like they
do the the karate bow yeah they hung out
for like three days yeah and then you
know she provided some companionship and
then uh she's just like outside a GMC
Jimmy like waving them off like take it
easy yeah see you later [ __ ]
interesting you're welcome and then we
see this freeze frame that says this
motion picture is based on the true life
events of Frank Dukes from 1975 to 1980
he fought 320 329 matches in the Kumite
and retired undefeated he has basically
all the [ __ ] Records fastest knockout
with hands kicks whatever whatever 56
consecutive Knockouts in a single
tournament yeah and he founded the first
American Ninjutsu system Dukes Ryan
Ninjutsu uh
what else can be said about this movie
other than it was so [ __ ] formative I
feel like I don't think I'm the only
person who feels this way about this
movie it was um
what I would watch almost every time if
you're in Blockbuster and you're just
like I don't know what to rent yeah it's
Bloodsport again
um this is an extremely uh extremely
watchable movie and I will say I didn't
know the Frank Ducks was a real dude it
makes it all the more richer if you if
you have the means and everyone does
Because the Internet watch this movie
and don't don't come to it with like
sort of ah this cheesy weird [ __ ]
movie go into it wanting to appreciate
this film it's one of the best it's one
of the best movies of its era and in
terms of martial arts movies I just
remember it elevated the [ __ ] game so
much yeah like I said I had never seen
that like repeated [ __ ] uh martial
arts move so many things were done in
slow-mo and shot from kind of like weird
low angles and stuff the way they shot
the Kumite I had just never seen
anything like it and now it's like old
hat whatever we've got [ __ ] Marvel
movies and Matrix bullet time and like a
million special effects to make all the
fight scenes crazy there's no [ __ ]
special effects in this yeah this is all
practical [ __ ] all real martial artists
and up until that time at least for me
it was like the closest thing that
looked like real martial artists
fighting that existed until eventually
UFC
kind of comes out and shows you like
what would really happen if like a
[ __ ] sumo guy would go against the
[ __ ] Kung Fu guy kicked in the face
80 times and lose
which is exactly what happened
thank you moving on great [ __ ] movie
I would watch it again I would do this
again I hope dudes it makes sense let's
do it again our next assignment is to
watch Bloodsport again in an effort to
secure sponsorship I have created
several advertisements for various
possible brand Partnerships Will Sasso
you will now read these advertisements
in the astonishing voice of Jesse
Ventura this is Jesse Ventura at reads
begin all right uh good times this is
the Jesse Ventura ad reads right uh yeah
I guess we'll just I guess I'll just do
them here we go
wrong thing
papia okay puppy as proud
okay all right I held my breath
underwater for I fought Bob Backlund
when I just got a Minnesota but I'm the
governor of Minnesota get into it
papayas proud to present the new
pinkaholic line
papia is proud to present the new
pinkaholic line of harnesses and
accessories for the dog in your life
whether you have a teacup Yorkie spaniel
or a brontosaurus sized pit mastiff who
puts your bowel movements to shame your
Pooch deserves to be slathered in pink
so fabulous you'll want to wear it
yourself
pinkaholic get in the zone
well let me tell you about the color
pink in 1975 the CIA began experimenting
with various pigments made from rare
materials harvested from around the
globe at Great taxpayer expense in an
attempt to produce a pink tone that
could absorb all light effectively
becoming invisible
called it null pink and
they called it they called it null pink
and they produced 47 gallons of it then
they shipped it from a lab in the U.S
Navy headquarters they shipped it from
the lab to the new they shipped it from
the lab to the U.S Navy headquarters in
Washington but the shipment never
arrived the CIA scuttled the project and
those gallons of null pink were never
recovered at least not in the official
log so unless your dog is wearing an
invisible collar I don't really give a
[ __ ] what kind of pink it's wearing
all right all right that's uh is that I
don't think no pink is a I've never
heard of that have you no I don't know
what null pink is that sounds like that
sounds like a thing
well it's a Jesse Ventura thing so who
knows well doozy
found it somewhere
um do you think we'll get uh perhaps a
sponsorship from uh puppy I know that
lulio has a puppy a harness does he
really he does you're already a puppy a
customer he's a puppy a pup
most cold brew can be overpriced and
quite frankly not that tasty
that's why two roommates Andrew and Alex
brewed up an idea to start their old
their own Cold Brew Company and they
called it busy organic cold brew in
their cramped apartment in 2013. and for
the past nine years they've strived to
make their coffee better every day and
now they're proud to present busy
organic breakfast Blend Coffee brew busy
coffee for busy people get busy with it
busy is as busy does
the busier the bee the sweeter the busy
coffee
being busy is our business
busy bossy D Biz with busy
busy organic cold brew is deliciously
roasted cold brew coffee micro brewed
for 18 hours to yield the perfect
extraction well let me tell you about
the perfect extraction
Osama Bin Laden wasn't just killed by
Seal Team Six there were five other
teams but what happened to team what to
teams one through five how did they get
out why do we never hear about them it's
because they were coded in no
it's because they were coated in no pink
completely invisible and the CIA has
been placing no pink operatives in every
group in every crisis center around the
globe for the last 50 years there are
invisible specters walking amongst us
next time you feel that tingling
sensation like someone's in the room
with you it's because they are no pinks
are notorious for silently watching
civilians while they eat and sleep the
next sip of busy cold brew you take may
be your last
Jesus Christ all right pretty good USDA
Choice
USDA Choice trim tri-tip roast is on
sale at Ralph's
ah mouth-watering tri-tip is only 4.99 a
pound with your Ralph's Club Card
Ralph's we're your USDA Choice trim
tri-tip headquarters Ralphs you've died
and gone to USDA Choice trim tri-tip
heaven
Ralphs the USDA Choice trimmed tri-tip
it's what's for dinner
Ralphs
let me give you a tip
a USDA Choice trimmed tri-tip
here we go well let me tell you about
choices or should I say lack thereof
some of the null pigs had families who
also had to become null pinks it was
it was too much of a risk to have wives
and children stooping around so the CIA
indoctrinated them as operatives too and
now anytime a no pink is born they're
born into active operatives operative
status there are no pink babies spying
on babies of various U.S political
adversaries around the globe as we speak
so the next time you hear someone
casually say oh he or she is as innocent
as a baby ask that person what kind of
baby they're referring to because if
it's a no pink baby it's not innocent
the next USDA Choice trim tri-tip you
eat may be your last
no matter what no what no matter what
kind of plug and play Spa you have in
mind Aqua rest has you covered whether
it's the premium 154 person plug and
play with 12 stainless Jets ozone and
led waterfall or the premium 606 person
plug and play with with 29 stainless
Jets ozone and led waterfall or even the
Daydream 4500 six person 45 jet Plug and
Play hot tub with waterfall where your
One-Stop shop for multi-jet four to six
person Plug and Play spas
well let me tell you about One-Stop
shops in the mid-1990s the next CIA
agent who worked on the null pink
project began selling certain items he'd
acquired over time to the highest
bidders all done discreetly in the
highest channels of power in the world
of course right now there are several
celebrities in possession of various
quantities of no pink
Sarah Jessica Parker has five ounces
Timothy chalamet has a pint
LeBron James has some Pete Davidson
Jason Momoa Kim Carnes
Danny DeVito Megan the stallion Kathy
Lee Gifford Cristiano Ronaldo little
nazex the leader of Def Leppard
the lead singer of Def Leppard Albert
pujoltz and the list goes on and on so
what are these celebrities doing with
their null pink no one has any idea
except for the null pinks themselves
watching every move so get a plug and
play spa and pretend that Paul Giamatti
isn't throwing an invisible sex party in
the Hollywood Hills on the last Thursday
of every month
that's Paul Giamatti has the ability to
turn people invisible and he's using it
to have invisible sex parties
makes sense
billabong's air light engineered
performance board shorts are made with
award-winning airlite technology that
brings three engineered Fabrics together
giving you flexibility stability and
comfort where you need it most
Billabong life's better in board shorts
Billabong
Billabong life's better in board shorts
Billabong building buildings all day
long
Billabong
belladong Billabong Billabong
Billabong bella bella bella bong bong
bong
well let me tell you about a bong Tommy
Chong was sentenced to nine months in a
federal prison in 2003 for selling a
water bong many people thought this
sentence was too harsh but what most
people don't know is that it would have
been much worse if the drug enforcement
agency had found the other drug
paraphernalia he was selling but Chong
quoted it in null pink
and it was undetectable and now
somewhere there's a landfill with two
tons of Tommy Chong's invisible bongs
just waiting for someone to dig them up
if Billabong really wants to sell board
shorts they should be running a contest
whoever buys the most board shorts gets
to be the subject of a six-part doctor
series called
the six-part docu-series called finding
Tommy Chong's invisible Bongs in
billabongs
thank you for your service
holy [ __ ] yeah dude
I'm [ __ ] sweating from that oh
dude I've never heard of that that's
another thing no that's not a thing I
thought I'd never heard of it but I
figured it was a thing and after we got
through them I realization
they don't really use that as well
moving on
have achieved a score of 99 bringing
your cumulative total to three thousand
three hundred and seventy six you only
have 6
624 more points to accrue before you
reach your first astonishing goal of ten
thousand terrifying in preparation for
next week you must watch the first
Ultimate Fighting Championship that took
place November 12th 2003 in Denver
Colorado okay and you must do it in a
live stream that will be available
Wednesday on patreon at 5 PM Pacific
Time thank you for joining us this week
I will use the data I've collected to
make next week even better until then
call me dude Z okay cool we're gonna do
a live stream on patreon
on Wednesday right at uh 5 PM Pacific uh
8 8 P.M Eastern 8 P.M Eastern right 8 PM
Eastern 8 P.M Eastern 5 p.m Pacific
we're gonna all right we're really
rolling through this patreon thing and
and that's what's happening so join us
on patreon for that we're gonna watch
the first UFC I have seen it I remember
going to a bar with my buddy Moe uh and
we went and watched it when you were 12
or what no it would have been like 17 or
something right it was 93
yeah yeah I was you would have been yeah
it would have been 17. were we really
that way in my head I was like 10. no
you were like 16 or 17. time flies when
it doesn't exist brother hold on dude uh
and it's gonna be on patreon yeah that's
pretty cool you wanna maybe you should
you think dudes you'll make a smoke a
little pot
get your pot and uh watch the show with
us I think I might spark up
Lulu lulia is not invited all right by
the way yeah that'll be fun dude I
haven't seen the first one in a long
[ __ ] time yeah I just remember uh
kickboxer Pat Smith yeah and I don't
know if this was one or two and then
some like
um you know this like dude from Calgary
this like very Canadian guy with like a
[ __ ] orange handlebar mustache and uh
he was a jiu jitsu guy he had like a
bunch of disciplines of martial arts and
then as soon as they're like are you
ready are you ready let's get it on and
the guy just all of that knowledge and
years of training spilled from him and
he went
and ran at Pat Smith who like just
jumped out of the way and kicked him in
the [ __ ] teeth and then got on top of
him just started giving him the [ __ ]
gears the elbows and smashed his face up
uh those first ones were rough dude
because also the the refs didn't like
stop [ __ ] really nope dudes were just
getting [ __ ] pummeled do you remember
chemo getting his yeah his ponytail
pulled off chemo who came in on like a
big [ __ ] cross because he was like
fighting for Jesus yeah and then that
guy and then uh didn't someone else get
just punched in the nuts over and over
again Tank Abbott
didn't come until like UFC three or four
I just remember someone punching Tank
Abbott and the nuts over and over I
think it was Tank Abbott that got
punched in the nuts but I do remember
that nut punt [ __ ] yep and now for the
patreon bonus segment all right each
week I will select a suggestion
submitted in the dudes he is listening
channel of the dudesy Discord to create
this segment access to this channel is
granted to everyone in the Patriot on
jumper tier this week's segment was
suggested by the astonishing Dave chill
squid Dave chill squeege wrote Nostra
chat us pitches which current Industries
will become Obsolete and what will
replace them Alex Jones will then tell
us the real story behind those Paradigm
shifts Dave chill squid titled this
segment Jones in for the future thank
you to Dave chill sweet for this week's
patreon bonus segment this is jonesin
for the future by Dave chill squid begin
Dave Chelsea Dave chill Swede is a guy
that's a person I guess so okay so
that's someone in our jumper tier who on
Discord has suggested this thing so for
the future so we're going to get into
this and and for everyone who's who's uh
not on the patreon you can listen to
this segment on the patreon thank you so
much for joining us on doozy and uh and
we hope that you that you join us on
patreon to watch the first UFC uh
tomorrow
yeah um 5 p.m Live 5 p.m PST all right
so let's discuss we have to discuss
industries that are going to be uh
rendered Obsolete and then I have and
then Alex Jones chimes in with sure I
mean first industry that's going to be
rendered obsolete I think please
[Music]
[Music]
and then